the EU is on high alert after turkish
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan said he
will no longer stop migrants from
breaching Turkey's borders to the West
in a tweet Turkey's interior minister
said more than 76,000 people had left
the country for the European Union
Greece rejects that number saying its
police have turned back on was 10,000
people the UN estimates at least 13,000
people are stuck along the borders
between Turkey Greece and Bulgaria Berta
wands move ends a deal between Turkey
and the EU meant to curb the influx of
refugees from Syria our correspondent
Julia Hahn is covering the story on the
ground and filed this report from the
Turkish Greek border the sign at the
Greek border says welcome but that's
just not the case it's the second day of
people heading here hundreds now wait to
be allowed across a chaotic makeshift
camp has sprung up open to the elements
people try to stay warm lighting fires
and dense smoke drifts through the air
sometimes it's teargas fired by the
Greek police this is one of the major
crossing points between Turkey and EU
member Greece it's been heavily guarded
in the past few years but as soon as
Turkish authorities announced they would
no longer stop refugees from trying to
cross into Europe hundreds of people
started arriving here and they easily
passed this border fence on the Turkish
side at the same time Greek border
police beefed up security and the border
over there remains closed so this is the
situation now hundreds of people many
with children and just a few belongings
stuck in the no man's land between the
two countries fearless and his family
sit a little further away five years ago
he fled from the Syrian city of Homs to
Turkey it's here where he met his wife
and it's here where their daughter was
born now they're on the road again
we heard on the news that the borders to
Europe are being opened a Ljubica bit us
we set off immediately by bus and taxi
from Izmir to hear Indiana Oh to booze
isn't it done
Cher I don't know how that worry now we
wait to actually open the border Arsenal
area big yes they paid 400 Turkish lira
for the trip that's around 60 euros a
lot of money for this family
at least they brought some supplies
water bread many have nothing at all the
desperation is most visible when a few
local volunteers arrive to distribute
food there isn't enough for everyone the
whole world must see this if you ask me
this is a shame for the entire planet
these people have been left to stay
outside in the cold
most of those waiting here came with the
firm belief that the border was indeed
open and that the tax the Europeans of
both had ruled in their favor the
realization that this is not true makes
it all the more bitter used for
political purposes they should not use
for Fugees like this now we know that
this is all a game nobody knows was a
result we just want someone to tell us
what will happen is a Sulha solution a
knowing what's in store this is what
everybody here wants fear us who even
here watches the news from Syria and the
many others who now say they want to
stay until the border is open
even though they sense that is unlikely
to happen joining me now is Dorian Jones
GW correspondent in Istanbul Dorian what
can you tell us about the situation on
the ground right now the numbers of
people's trying to cross into Greece and
Bulgaria are markedly increasing
throughout the day there's been reports
now of increasing clashes with Greek
frontier police trying to push back
using teargas stun grenades as a growing
frustration among the people is
increasing and the concern is that this
will those tensions will increase as a
numbers increase and at the moment
increasing desperation and they realize
that they can't get across and many
before they have nowhere else to go and
the given the fact that Ankara has given
its message that it will continue to
allow its borders to be open they say
that there is a change in policy now
over the question of hosting refugees
those numbers will inspect to continue
to increase in the coming days you know
during I almost feel compelled to say
here we go again I mean thousands of
migrants have already crossed the border
if the EU refuses to open its arms
what's likely to happen to those people
well I think this will bring back
memories of 2015 where you saw maybe as
many as a million people trying to well
effectively leaving Turkey and going to
Greece and Bulgaria and causing
triggering one of the biggest migration
crisis that Europe has faced since the
Second World War and that will be the
concern in Brussels it hasn't reached
that point yet but the fact that as days
continue in the fact that this policy of
anchors doesn't appear to be in reverse
there will be the growing concern that
our Europe again will be faced with a
massive migration problem we are getting
reports of large numbers of boats
crossing from Turkey to the Greek
islands Greece is already struggling
with a number of refugees it's already
having the fear is that they are now
facing a major increase as Ankara is
resolute on this is dismiss any
criticism it says any criticism of this
policy is complete hypocrisy on
Europeans sigh given the fact that
little support they've given Ankara
Ankara says it's patience is run out we
can't take any more refugees and the
further and the fact is that we're no
longer gonna stop those microts who want
to into Europe and they say this is your
responsibility now during not much more
time but just briefly president and
Irwin opened the border to Europe for
Refugees in response to the deadly
bombing of Turkish soldiers in Syria is
Turkey essentially being drawn deeper
into the conflict in Eid Lib well that's
certainly appears to be the case this is
definitely markedly increasing the
confrontation between Turkish forces and
Syrian regime we understand that to
Syrian regime jets were shot down today
we also get reports that Turkish forces
have destroyed the Syrian regime's
Aleppo military air base today and they
are pounding regime forces all across
Italy province destroying supply lines a
plane they've killed over 2,000 Syrian
soldiers and the ROO and the expectation
is they are only just getting started
possibly ultimately the aim could be
even to retake Aleppo for the Syrian
rebels message among courage this is
just beginning
Dorian Jones in Istanbul thank you so
much